Sandra Day O'Connor made history when
she became the first woman to serve on
the Supreme Court in 1981 former
President Ronald Reagan appointed her to
the position and the Senate confirmed
her unanimously during her nearly 25
years on the country's highest court
O'Connor was considered by many to be
the most powerful woman in America
Amerika author evan Thomas's new book
first Sandra Day O'Connor gives what the
New York Times calls a fascinating and
revelatory portrait of the Justice both
on the bench and off Evan Thomas good
morning I know you had extraordinary
access by the O'Connor family you spoke
to her son's 7 justices 94 of her 108
law clerks what do you want us to know
about Sandra Day O'Connor she looks like
a kind of formidable middle-aged lady in
those photos
she was actually lively and fun she
liked to dance she liked dirty jokes she
had great human intelligence she was a
great leader partly because she knew how
to listen her body would get very still
she would really listen to you but she
also knew how to dish it out yeah I mean
she this is a woman in a man's world
when she was coming up she really was
the first 12 years before Ruth Bader
Ginsburg she grew up in a she grew up on
this ranch that was a man's world she
learned how to fire a rifle before she
was 10 and drive a truck before she was
10 very self-reliant very tough but very
great human intelligence she knew how to
deal with others you know in reading
your book though I'm reminded she is she
the most consequential woman in American
history to date well she preserved
affirmative action and abortion for 25
years that is no small thing you know
the Conservatives thought when she got
on the court those things are gone
they're the bete noire is of course of
the right wing and and she preserved
them
she optimizing but this is the key is
it's not that she was a liberal activist
at all she's a conservative she was a
Republican conservative but she
understood the public mood and she found
these compromises these middle ways to a
lot to reflect really what America was
thinking course she graduated from
Stanford
along with chief justice rehnquist who
was a couple years older than her then
they served on the court together for
more than two decades you discovered
something about their relationship we'd
known that they had sort of dated right
well in while in college a law school my
wife Ossie and I were going through her
letters and lo and behold there are 14
love letters from bill Rehnquist who had
just finished being a law student this
is 1952 at Stanford and Sandra day as
she was then and along about love letter
number six he says sandy will you marry
me they had never even told their
families about this this was totally new
and I think they didn't want to be
embarrassed about it it's a sweet story
bill Rehnquist ended up marrying
somebody he truly loved and she married
somebody she truly loved but but they
were they were an item what lessons did
she learned from her mother he point out
in the book this is important her father
was a adoring and powerful figure a real
cowboy but he was to be rough he could
be harsh and her mom who was very
elegant lady in this dusty ranch always
wore a dress learned how to not be
bullied by her father but really how not
to take the bait when he came on too
strong to her she just had a way of just
rolling with this is so important we're
justice O'Connor isn't one of the only
women the first woman how to deal with
men there's so many great things in this
book your research is incredible it is a
page-turner really important for all of
us to learn about one of the most
influential if not the most influential
woman in American history Kevin Thomas
thank you first Sandra Day O'Connor is
on sale today